whilst the El Clasico is not a derby in  the traditional sense and that the two  teams don't come from the same city it  still has all the hallmarks of a classic  derby the intensity their rivalry in the  hatred the two sets of fans have for  each other  when the clásico comes around it is just  number one is topology  a classic case timer see I think it's  one of the biggest fancy in the world  dream  [Music]  [Applause]  in the newspapers usually there's five  six seven days of 20-page build-up every  single day it's just enormous  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  people fill them up yeah it's our  different view  [Music]  if you  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  you  [Music]